let's now
explain to ourselves as you could say a
more formal
communication of the integral test
integral
test
so it tells us that if we assume
that we have some f of x
if we have some f of x that is positive
positive
continuous
continuous continuous
and decreasing
and decreasing on some interval
on
so starting at k and including k all the
way to infinity then we can make one of
two statements
we could say either
that if
the improper integral from k to infinity
of f of x
dx
is convergent
then
the sum
the infinite series from n is equal to k
to infinity
of
f
of n
is also convergent
is
also
convergent
convergent and this is actually the case
that we saw when we looked at 1 over n
squared but i'll look at that in a
second but the second claim that we
could make or the second
deduction that we might be able to make
using the integral test is if it's the
other way around
that if the integral from k to infinity
the improper integral of f of x dx
is divergent
divergent
then the same thing is true for the
corresponding infinite series
then
this infinite series right over here is
also going to be
is also
divergent
and as i already mentioned we in the
last video we already saw this in the
case of f of x is equal to 1 over x
squared we saw that since
since
the integral from 1 to infinity of
of 1 over x squared
over 1 over x squared dx is convergent
in fact it equals 1
it equals 1. because of that we were
able we were able to say that the sum
from n equals the sum from n is equal to
to infinity
of
over
n squared is also convergent
also convergent
and now we can see an example where we
go the other way
for example we know that this integral
let me write it the integral down
let's start with this integral from 1 to
infinity
not of f of x is equal to 1 over x
squared but let's say that f of x is
equal to 1 over x actually let me just
write that down let's just start with
f of x
is equal to 1 over x
it definitely meets our conditions that
it is positive and let's say we're going
to contin we're going to consider it
over the interval
over
the interval from 1
to
infinity
so it meets this first constraint over
this interval 1 over x is positive it is
continuous and it is decreasing as x
increases f of x decreases so the
integral test should apply so let's see
what this what what the what the
improper integral from 1 to infinity of
this would be
so
if we take if we go from 1 to infinity
of 1 over x
of 1
over x
dx
this is equal to
we could write this as
the limit
as t approaches
infinity of the definite integral from 1
to t
of 1 over x dx
which is equal to
the limit as t approaches infinity of
take the anti-derivative
is going to be of the natural log of x
the natural log of x
going from 1 to t
1 to t we could do that well it's really
the absolute value of x but we're
dealing with positive x's here so it's
just going to be the natural log of x
which is going to be
the limit as t approaches infinity of
of the natural log of t i can even say
the natural log of the absolute value of
t which is going to be the natural log
of t because it's positive t's
minus the natural log of 1 minus the
natural log of the absolute value of 1.
well the natural log of 1 is 0 so it's
going to be the natural log of t the
limit as that approaches infinity but
the limit as that approaches infinity
this is going to be unbounded this is
going to go to infinity this right over
here is divergent so this right over
here
is
divergent
so this is
and because this is divergent we can
then say
we can then say by the integral test
we can then say the integral test once
again our function over this interval
positive continuous decreasing
we saw that this improper integral right
over here is divergent and then by the
second point of the integral test we can
say therefore
and i haven't rigorously proved it yet
but hopefully i gave you a good
intuitive justification in the previous
video that the integral of the the
infinite series from n equals one to
infinity of one over n which is the
harmonic series that this is
also
this is also
this is also divergent
so we've already shown that the harmonic
series is divergent using that very
beautiful elegant proof
by orem i think i'm probably
mispronouncing his name they'll use the
comparison test but just like this we
have used the integral test to show
that it is also divergent and once again
let's remember what the whole motivation
of the integral test is
let me draw f of x is equal to 1 over x
so f of x is equal to 1 over x would
look like
do my best attempt here
so let's say that's one
two
three
that is
one
two
and so see when
x is one f of x is one when x is two f
of x is one one-half
one-third that's one-half here it'll be
two over here so it looks like this so
this is f of x is equal to one over n
and once again we see that that over the
interval we care about from one to
infinity it's definitely positive
continuous and
decreasing
and if we look at this sum right over
here we could view this sum as
as let's do that let me write it down so
the sum
from n equals 1 to infinity of 1 over n
is equal to 1
plus
1 half
1 3 and of course we keep going on and
on and on and on
in this case since we want to show this
divergent we could say hey look this is
an overestimate of
of this area here let me be clear so we
have this area
we have this area in green
which is what the improper integral is
denoting so that right over there is the
improper integral from 1 to infinity of
of 1 over x
dx now you could view this as an over
estimate of that area so this first
this one right over here you could say
that this is this one height times
one width so that's that block right
over there that's the area of that is
going to be equal to one
then
this over here one half you could view
that as the area of the next block
of the next block
and so you can kind of view this as a
left-sided riemann sum i guess is one
way to think about it and so this is
going to be one half yeah left-sided
riemann sum so this is going to be
one-half and then the one-third
is going to be this one
is going to be this one and notice
they're all
the the actual area we care about that
the improper integral it's all contained
in these blocks
so this is going to be an over is going
to be larger than this but we've already
seen that this is unbounded towards
infinity this is divergent so if this is
larger than this and this is divergent
this goes to infinity then this must
also go to infinity so that's exactly
where the integral test is coming from